hello believe nation welcome to another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here with my special guest and friend
tom tate from Aweber Aweber is the email
marketing service that I have personally
used for over a decade and probably a
lot of you guys found this hangout from
a newsletter that came from a weber and
we've got this regular see was going on
and super excited to talk to you about
today being your day with Tom tape
welcome back tom hey how are you I'm
glad to be here last time we had Tom on
we were talking about time management
and had a organizer day and he was one
of our most popular guys was it hey we
gotta bring them back share some love
now I when making this just just for
some I want your opinion where do you
put the highlight cuz I put it on the
today you think it's like today's your
day or today is your day that's a really
great question i think that the emphasis
is is today because i think that that's
the most important thing you could
probably probably put the emphasis on
the you're you know just to call people
out and say listen I know you're sitting
on the couch or you know maybe you're
driving to and from work but today is
your day and the emphasis for me is
really on today I love it well then I
guessed right I'm glad I'm glad we did
that I'm repping the Toronto Blue Jays
the guys in the chat yeah I wanted me to
wear the hat today so we got it on uh so
for the next hour guys we're going to be
answering your questions help when you
figure out how to stay motivated and
getting through the hurdles that you
have in your business Tom I know this
has been a passion project of yours at
Aweber do you want to just talk quickly
before getting to the questions about
what today is your day is about the
campaign that you're running why I mean
so much to you yeah absolutely so as
Evan mentioned I'm from Aweber we are an
email service provider we provide a
platform for people to send emails and
to really get started and and be
successful with email marketing and you
know one of the things that we found
from talking to so many small business
owners and so many entrepreneurs is that
they hit a point where they just get
stuck
and it could be they get stuck before
they even get started so they know they
have this this uh this yearning to be an
entrepreneur they have this yearning to
start a business or pursue a passion and
they don't even know where to begin at
the beginning and then you have people
who do take that leap and they get
started and they begin building their
business but they get stuck at a
different point they don't know how to
take it from this level to the next
level or they don't know the next move
they need to make with content marketing
or how to scale so we wanted to address
address that feeling of being stuck and
provide people with opportunities to
consume some content that we put
together to not only inspire them to
take that next step but also really like
hold their hand and help them take that
next step so we have a microsite that I
believe you and Michael Mike Smith
talked about before we even launched it
but if you go to Aweber calm / today
you'll check out our site where we have
success stories but also these awesome
checklists and for me the check the
checklists are the most important thing
they're really going to help you do some
of the next big marketing activities
that you may have been kind of dragging
your feet wanting to do but haven't done
yet 11 then we've been linking up a
different link that's in the description
and the run yep yep there are those
check those are available from that link
as well as so if you go to Aweber calm /
entrepreneurs dot HTM that is our home
for all things Evan Carmichael and we
have a few resources and links to our
previous sessions that we did with Mike
Smith and Monica and then we have the
final block is a link to this session
that you're watching right now and a
link from there to go to check out the
different checklists that we have for
the today's your day campaign I love it
yes so you know for the entrepreneurs
who are struggling to get started or
they started in their struggling to keep
going or brick to your comfort zone how
do they make today their day what do
they have to think about what mindsets
do they have to break through what
advice do you have for someone who's
like struggling to take
action and make today their day so I
think it's uh it starts with a mindset
shift I really do think that you need to
wake up or at some point during your day
you need to take a deep breath and you
need to consider that today is your day
I mean I think that it's it starts first
and foremost with that mindset and then
you know once you realize that you you
have what it takes to do it I for me
it's just writing down on a piece of
paper what the next step is like what is
that next thing that you need to do and
if you're not quite sure that's when you
can go check out resources like you know
your YouTube channel resources like some
of the checklist that we put together
there's plenty of entrepreneur
entrepreneurial resources out there to
help you identify the next step but the
key is to really just have that mindset
shift declare that today is your day
write down what your next step is what
goal you want to achieve and then move
forward with that it's it's all about
taking that first step and that was kind
of the inspiration for this campaign
because I think a lot of people feel
like they're not capable of you know
maybe recording a YouTube video or
starting a podcast or you know creating
a shareable image nicely designed
shareable image that might seem too
intimidating for people but I think once
you just do it and you take that first
step you'll surprise yourself but it
starts with that mindset shift I love it
well you guys have got eyes for an hour
to answer your questions to help you
figure out your path of the day and just
go to the town on the side writing your
questions and Tom and I will feel them
first one comes in from VA vinay hope i
pronounced it ok asking how do you stay
energized and motivated for me staying
motivated is about staying focused so I
think I want to tribute this to Greg
mccowen and he wrote a book called
essentialism which is a really great
book and
I he writes I forget if this is in his
book i heard him say it somewhere else
but every day write down six things that
you want to accomplish that day your top
three goals for for your professional
life and your top three goals for your
personal life and then cross out five
things right so it's all about you know
like really identifying what is the most
important thing to you and I think once
you do that once you've really identify
you know the why you know like why do
you get up in the morning and do what
you do and if you're doing something
that you don't want to do what is it
that you want to do and what are the
steps to get you there so if you're
tired of your nine to five and you want
to be an entrepreneur and you want to
start your own business or you want to
take your life in a different direction
you can do that and it's just a matter
of mapping out what steps you need to
take and I think identifying the one
thing that you need to do each day to
help you get there is really important
and that's what gets me energized it not
just identifying staying focused to the
one thing but you know I realizing why
why you're doing it you know so I I have
two kids and I think about my kids all
day you know they keep me energized I
think about you know when I come come to
work and try to do my most meaningful
work I'm not just doing it to support my
family but to you know leave a strong
legacy for my kids and I think everyone
has a different reason like that and
it's it's helpful to identify i mean i
agree Henderson with Tom I think it's
important that especially as
entrepreneurs you know I mean tom has a
job thank Allah he loves his job he's
growing through that but as entreprise
you get to create your own job get to
create your own business get your own
dreams and your own life and it better
be to do something that you are
passionate about there have been moments
you know I'm sure Vinay there's been
moments in your life where you have been
excited what you have been passionate
where you have like gone without sleep
and lost track of time what was it that
you were doing and how can you find that
zone again and if you are waking up and
doing too many things that you don't
like then it's hard like you can only
force yourself to do things that you
don't like for so long before you just
quit and so it's not just trying to get
to I'm
billion dollars just trying to get to
you know the car the house or whatever
it is that the outcome goals that you
trying to accomplish its enjoying the
process to along the way like you like
doing the work you know I'm sure Tom
does a lot of stuff every day that I
would look guys like man Tom I don't
know how you do that they're nuts yeah
like I can't stand that stuff and people
look at me and try to jump into my rule
and be like new work too hard like I
can't do the working but you know while
we're doing it I don't see this work
like I love doing most you know of the
process everything is amazing but you
have to enjoy doing the work and if you
look forward to doing the work and it's
much easier to stay energized and
motivated as well I'll add to that to
another thing that that helps me stay
energized and motivated is setting up a
feedback loop and what I mean by that is
if you're creating something of value
for someone so whether you're you know
if you're a blogger youtube if you
create YouTube videos if you're a small
business owner who provides a service
set up a feedback loop with your your
consumers your customers and just
constantly remind yourself that you're
doing it for them as well as yourself so
you're providing value to someone else
and whenever you have an opportunity to
get feedback from that person that
you're providing value to that feedback
can be very very valuable not just to
shape the direction of your business or
shape the direction of the content you
create or the purpose you you fulfill
but to keep you going and to keep you
exciting keep you energized and remind
you why you do what you do in the first
place I love it tie me that question
kind of part 2 from Vinay was asking
about books or resources that you
recommend I mean we've touched on the
checklist that you guys have created you
mention my youtube channel other other
books that you recommend that help you
there that have helped you yeah I think
so I like the classics so the the 7
Habits of Highly Effective People by
Stephen Covey it is so old I mean I read
my dad's copy when I was a super young
kid like oddly young I read my dad's
copy of this book and it really changed
the way I think I think about how your
your daily habits shape your ability to
be successful
and your ability to really thrive not
just working as an entrepreneur but
working with other others too so I would
absolutely recommend that if you haven't
read it i think it's an incredible book
i did mention essentialism earlier by a
by Greg makan that would that was a good
one too because I to me what that did
was it reminded me that you can't do
everything at once um and that I think
that's a that's a has it that that's
something that holds us back as
entrepreneurs is the feeling that we
need to do everything and we need to
accomplish everything ourselves and we
need to do everything right away uh you
know a lot of this very much is is
taking baby steps you know working your
way towards your goals and essential
isn't really helped me kind of map that
out um and I'm excited to check out your
books so I'm gonna I'm gonna plug your
book right now because I'm excited I
think that's going to be really helpful
um you know just the idea of of the one
word I think that ties into this you
know because I think it gives you
something to it's a constant you know
you just gonna hold on to so I'm really
excited to check that out for sure cool
I appreciate that um the one book that
you know now i'm not a huge book reader
um i just i love videos i consume video
content better but the one book that
really helped me when I was a younger
entrepreneur getting started was
radicals and visionaries that's now out
of print but basically what it was was
two to three pages of different
entrepreneurs and their stories and I
would just wake up every day and read
one story of a famous entrepreneur and
get one the motivation that like look
how Oprah started and look at how these
people started you know with less
resources and yr what I already have
right now and then also got some
practical strategies and what i could do
i get an idea from you know what that
entrepreneur did to grow their business
I so I read a page I read a new
entrepreneur which 23 pages every day to
kind of stay inspired now I do it
through the videos like I watch my own
youtube channel i gotta love Janice
entrepreneurs um so it's cool i'm like i
like though that you were a young and
reading 7 habits yes yes
I would also add to that to podcasts are
great so if you can find a podcast that
really speaks to you I listened to Gary
Vaynerchuk podcast I you know I think
it's really just the audio from the the
askgaryvee show but I I like podcasts
because you can listen to them while
you're driving I've listened to them
while you know doing the dishes mowing
the lawn you know like when you have
this like kind of idle time where you
have to be doing something but you could
be feeding your your energy and feeding
your mind with some content that's going
to help you be a better entrepreneur
take the next step finding the right
podcast is really helpful I love it next
up J reyez do you see a planet of 7
billion people seven billion people all
doing what they want each day I I mean I
think so I you know there are dirty jobs
i remember that show dirty jobs where
like people had to do things that most
people would find repulsive but I
honestly think that you know for every
job that needs to be done there is the
perfect person who's suited for that job
and wants to do that job and is
passionate about that job and I think
that if you can get you know if we did
live in a world where everybody was
doing what they wanted to do I be
curious to see what that world was like
because I think it would be pretty
mutually beneficial for everybody yeah i
agree hun percent and you can always
count on j rise for the high level meta
you know type of type of questions i
agree like i'd like to tell the story of
whoever you think the the best
basketball player in the world Michael
Jordan is I would say this not Michael
Jordan it's it's some guy was a manager
at starbucks because he never actually
explored the idea of playing basketball
like he never even picked up a ball and
so everybody has the opportunity to be
genius level talent Michael Jordan level
talent at something you just got explore
and figure out what that thing is and I
don't think that we encourage enough
exploration you know you encouraged to
go to school and get a job and then just
stand
I jump for the rest of your life and
like if you want to leave trying to be a
doctor to go learn the paint it's
massively discouraging where that might
be where you have that genius level
talent and so uh I mean that's one of
the main things that drives what I do
and my channel I know it drives Tom and
this campaign to is to try to help
people and cover their talents and
believe in themselves and take action
don't wait and do something right now
but if it's small just today to get
started because a a planet of 7 billion
people doing what they're great at and
genius level talent at is to Thomas
point beneficial to everybody I love it
okz know how do you prevent yourself
from thinking tomorrow is my day I so
for me it's it's all about that you know
that focus writing down what you're
trying to accomplish and again you know
a lot of this is taking baby steps so
you know today's your day tomorrow's
your day and the next day is your day
you know like every day has to be your
day but really the the spirit behind
today's your days is to take a look at
the things that you've been putting off
and making it a point that you know
you're you're not going to wait until
tomorrow to at least get started so you
might not accomplish everything today
but you are going to take that first
step today and that's really what put
matters and that was the spirit of the
campaign because we found you know in
talking to so many entrepreneurs that
you know once they took a risk and and
created uh you know that first youtube
video that you know that first blog post
um they prove to themselves that they
were capable of doing it they got the
ball rolling um and they checked off you
know just getting that first one done
off the list and sometimes it's the most
challenging thing is doing the first one
and it's it's not going to be good and I
think that's another thing too is we
need to understand as entrepreneurs is
that first youtube video or that first
podcast that you record or you know the
first assignment that you take on as a
small business owner um it's not going
to be great and you know I probably it's
not going to be great and it's not going
to be without its its its pain points um
but you did it and I think that's what
what
matters is you did it you got it done
you put it out there people saw it and
you're going to learn from it you're
going to keep going so that to me that's
how you prevent prevent it from prevent
that tomorrow's your day mentality's
just say you know today I'm going to do
it and if it's a failure that's fine I'm
gonna learn from it I'm gonna get up I'm
gonna you know start again tomorrow and
I'm gonna keep moving yeah I expect to
suck at the start yeah i agree that
that's okay that's part of the process i
think the challenge with thinking
tomorrow's my day is that tomorrow you
won't actually do it yes and this next
thing is how is the next day I was the
next thing but the best thing to do is
when you have a goal to take some kind
of immediate action towards achieving
that goal so I'm small thing sending
email to somebody set up a phone call do
a little bit of research some small
things so that you start building
momentum like Tom said ah because what
happens is you get these like you get
bold you have this idea i'm gonna make a
youtube video I've never done it I'm
scared but I'm gonna go out and do it
and you get that energy and excitement
and then the next day it's gone yeah
you're not dumb not bold anymore you've
lost this happened to me today I had to
have a hard conversation with somebody
on my team today to help them through
something that he's facing and it all
came last night and I had this vision
for what I'm gonna say and how I'm going
to approach it and I was so confident
and so bold and doing it and then I woke
up two days ago that's that's that's
really bold i don't know if i should
lead with that you know i don't know if
that's the best way to do it and even
just recognizing that said ok now i have
to leave with it I gotta make sure I do
it I'm not like be afraid you know don't
let the voices kind of sure take me back
to the rational you know safe path
always uh and i think that's that's what
it is like you have your life and you
have these moments in your life where
you want to break free and do something
different and skinner you knew and
people might disapprove of it and so you
have to do something when you're in that
zone because you won't give back there
tomorrow it'll disappear tomorrow so you
gotta do something small especially can
commit to somebody else so you have to
show up the next day to do it I think
it's super important it takes carriage
to it takes a lot of courage but I think
that's you know part of the process is
kind of building up that courage
and so to the question how do you
prevent yourself from thinking tomorrow
is my day as soon as that even comes to
my mind like i'll do that tomorrow or
I'll do that next week or whenever that
should start to be a trigger for you to
do something now like I'm not like
tomorrow is not in my vocabulary anymore
I'm gonna do it now uh what I'm training
myself to do is anytime I'm thinking of
something that I want to do and then I
I'm afraid of other people's judgment
that I know I have to do it like i
wanted to me o my son wears different
colored socks all the time is a string
example but he always wears different
colors saw he never matches the socks a
matter how much you like try to give him
he'll never wear the same color socks I
don't let that's not you pretty cool
like what if I go out and for they not
wear the same color socks and then the
the immediate thing that came back was
oh well what how are people going to
judge me that I have one gray sock and
one orange sock and then because I was
afraid of their judgment I had to go and
do it yeah yep instead of backing down
so so they know if you guys watching
whenever you feel that impulse is saying
I'll do it tomorrow try to catch
yourself and just find a small way to do
it today yeah that's awesome you got me
excited Zeno okay um lorena i'm starting
my own educational consulting business
educational consulting business what are
some out-of-the-box ideas you would
suggest to create a client list so out
of the box you know I would actually say
start inside the box and go with a few
methods that are tried and true you know
and and then expand and get creative
based on that you know I'm very much a
start inside the box and then work your
way outside of the box type of person
especially when you're building a
business when you're building from the
ground up so for me it would be
educational consults consultancy start
start building a Content hub so whether
that's a blog or whether that's a
podcast or youtube series just start put
out content that shows that you are very
knowledgeable in your field that you
have the authority on that shows that
you have the passion to do what you want
to do and tie it together so if it's
thematic that's fantastic and then start
pushing your content out and one of the
best ways that I found to connect with
potential prospects if if you're doing
this virtually like if you don't have to
meet with someone face-to-face in your
hometown um Twitter search is fantastic
I really think it's a great tool so if
you can you know hop on Twitter search
and try to find conversations that are
happening around your niche um it it's a
great opportunity not just to go in not
to go in and sell yourself and really
spam people and kind of put your product
in front of them but if you have a very
valuable youtube series or valuable
podcasts that speaks to a conversation
that's already happening just offer up
that content with no expectation of
anything return but just offer that
value to them that's a really great way
to get in front of people with some
survival stuff I think it's a pretty
out-of-the-box answer tom to suggestion
box there you go I like it um yeah I'd
like to build on counts when I also say
when you're building content make sure
you have half a newsletter or anything
mean absolutely ah if people are
visiting your website and they love what
you wrote to them on Twitter a lot of
people are just going to hire you on the
spot where if you have a newsletter that
people can subscribe to its a low entry
way into sub building relationship and
then send them content consistently on a
regular basis where its value or its
continuing to build that relationship so
not just rely on somebody to remember
that they visited your website a month
ago and to call you up another strategy
I would add is I would look at making
alliances and partnerships like who is
already selling to your target audience
and how can you work out some kind of
arrangement so that by talking to them
they can introduce you to their clients
what is some mutually beneficial way
that you can get introductions to their
clients because you're adding
you through that process um I think both
of those both of those strategies will
help you yeah as email marketers one of
the things that we are confronted with
is the mentality that email marketing
really is just sending a newsletter like
a one-time newsletter like a weekly
updates newsletter or monthly updates
newsletter but email can be a powerful
tool for this type of lead generation if
you set up what we like to call an email
course so you can set up an automated
series of emails to go out and basically
structure like a course so you can do
like a four-week course or six week
course where one email will go out each
week and in each email you can have a
call to action to get in touch with you
and and to you know potentially utilize
your services or purchase your products
so it's a good way to build strong
relationships through through email but
also promote what you do and it's all
automated which is fantastic saves you a
lot of time as an entrepreneur yeah your
goal is to build trust build credibility
I have a lot of people who respond to my
emails saying they they feel like they
know me and he asked me about you know
my son and my wife and my trip and like
I know zero about them but because I'm
sharing it then they feel like they know
me they like me they trust me and then
if people feel like they had that
connection to you not that you have to
share a lot of personal details
sincerely but if they know your story
then otherwise is so important to you
they know why you're doing this you know
they know the kind of work that you do
why you're so passionate about it who
you've worked with you know if you can
share bits about yourself on the story
that is still value add then people will
feel like they know you trust you
through the email sequence that you send
out and it's way easier for for you to
stay top of mine and then land deals
through them because you built that
relationship and really two times won't
you just set it up once you set up the
autoresponder sequence so that like
every seven days or every 30 days or
whatever it is they're getting a new hit
from you with more value about whatever
topic you're an expert in all right
next is sherry my problem is I do too
many things during the day I like to do
this might be back to our time
management center I do too many things
you today I'd like to do but not all are
towards my business I garden I build a
fence watch the grandkids and I'm trying
to stay focused so yeah this totally
goes back to a conversation that Evan
and I had a while back about how to
manage your time effectively and I think
that they're there are enough hours in
the day to do what you need to do and
still find time for leisure and still
find time for family and still find time
for all the activities that make life
worth living obviously i highly
recommend i'm going to recommend two
things we won't go into much detail on
both but you can definitely google both
and learn more about them the first is
something i talked about the first time
around which is the pomodoro technique
and the Pomodoro Technique basically
it's loose and you can adapt it to your
needs but you work on one thing or a set
of things for 25 minutes and that's an
important increment so you set a timer
for 25 minutes and you focus on the
thing that you want to do and you work
on just that and you turn off social
media and you turn off the TV and
anything that's going to distract you
you really just try to isolate yourself
from distractions stay focused on that
one thing and then at the end of that
twenty five minute break whether you're
done or not you take a five-minute break
so you work for 25 minutes take a
five-minute break check social media do
all the leisurely things you want to do
maybe do some jumping jacks go for a
walk bathroom break whatever whatever it
is and then you come back and you do
another Pomodoro another 25 minute
increment it's a really good way to stay
focused so you don't jump from thing to
thing and then what you can do is just
schedule a you know I'm going to do
three or four of these 25 minute
increments and then after that I'm going
to go garden for an hour or I'm going to
go where I have to watch my grandkids so
I'm going to try
begin as much of the pomodoros as I can
in the morning because I know I'm going
to be watching my grandkids in the
afternoon so you can really start to
structure your date your days this way
and if you keep a physical checklist
you'll start to see things getting
crossed off and I absolutely recommend
keeping a physical checklist just
because there is a there's a mental
trigger that happens when you actually
cross something off of a list like I do
believe that the physical act of
crossing something off of the list
really helps your morale and helps give
you energy and helps you to continue to
move forward and get you super pumped in
super amped to just keep crossing things
off the list it almost becomes a game a
competition with yourself you know to
see how much you can cross off in a day
so I absolutely recommend that the other
thing I recommend is find an online tool
a free online tool that works for you to
help you organize and execute all your
to do's so the two that I really like
our asana so I believe it's a sauna asin
a calm and Trella of tre llo calm and
those two tools will just basically
provide you with an opportunity to
categorize the work that you want to do
straight down to the to do list the
checklist level and then help you
prioritize so if you can get a system
for managing your time and a system for
managing your work and really just try
to optimize that I believe that you will
find your being more productive and
efficient with the time you have now
give you time later to binge on netflix
or you know listen to some leisure
podcast play some video games ever and i
know you like to go salsa dancing so you
can find time with that you know so i
think it's just important you know to
make time for the fun stuff and then use
your other time wisely and efficiently
to get to get the work done Tom for your
second point about having a physical
list that you can scratch things off is
that like like having a book that you're
writing it down or is a list online
through a tool enough for you just
clarifying that either or so I'd like a
sana because as you're as you're
checking things off in a sauna every
once in a while they have this animation
where a little unicorn flies across the
screen and that is I love it it's just a
cute little touch that they put into
their app and it's it's fun and and they
have a mobile app so like everywhere I
go I have my to-do lists with me and I
have them categorized work to do xand
personal to do's you know so I keep
everything really um uh organized in
that in that sense but I also keep a
little notebook with me to keep some to
do's down in the notebook as well so it
whatever works for you I think it's just
habit somewhere and make sure that
whatever you're using gives you that
little adrenaline rush whenever you go
across things off I love it um sherry
for me I live and die by my calendar I
think you got to put the things that are
important to your life in your calendar
and not just constantly be reacting to
what's going on right your grandkids
come over and then that blows up your
day or you're not sure we're gonna do
today so you know paint the fence or do
your garden where if you take the time
to whatever it is once a month once a
week once a quarter kind of figure out
what is important to me for me to be
happy as a grandmother as a mother as an
entrepreneur and then what is my
schedule look like where do I need to
put the the big rocks in first to
understand these are things I need to
get done for me to be happy these are
things I need to get done and put them
in your calendar so that you're not
faced with a situation where things keep
running over and you don't get time to
work on your business right you got to
make the time and I find having that
process where you sit down and plan out
your schedule for me is insanely helpful
because otherwise left to my own devices
I'll just get lost in something and then
forget to do the thing i forgot i gotta
talk to tom at one o'clock ya go ahhh
Alec Saunders Brody is asking what is
the most important skill in business wow
that's a big one
so I will steal I will borrow from again
Gary Vaynerchuk and he talks about this
all the time and I'll you know steal
something that he says all the time
which is he emphasizes self-awareness
and III don't know if you would call
that a skill or a quality in this case
but I think practicing self awareness in
business is really important and what I
mean by that is having the ability to
step outside of yourself and look at
what you're doing and evaluating
objectively am i working on the right
things am I utilizing my time as well as
I can I am I putting out enough effort
and I the best person for this job like
that's a really important thing to ask
yourself if you're doing all the small
business accounting for your small
business and and you're not good at that
and it's taking too much time and it's
keeping you from doing the things that
really add value that you as an
individual add value to your company
maybe you shouldn't be doing the
accounting maybe it's time to hire an
accountant and I think it it takes some
level of self-awareness to be able to
step outside and say hey I can't do
everything I need to focus I need to
work on the right things to grow my
business and this is it and I'm going to
I'm going to do it and today is my day
to do it and I think that takes a level
of self-awareness I like it if you asked
what the most important thing in
business I would probably say passion
and not just in business but in life
passion for your doing I don't think
that would I would call that a skill
though so so what I might add is just a
willingness to learn uh because if you
have passion and you willing to learn
you can figure anything out yep right
like I don't have to know how to do I
don't have to be a master craftsman yet
but if I'm super passionate about it
i'll pick it up i'll learn like if i'm
interested in learning it I will figure
it out and a lot of entrepreneurship is
just figuring stuff out like yeah you're
creating your own path you're not just
following somebody else blindly you
gotta build your own path
and along the way is a bunch of stuff
that happens that you have no idea how
to do and you just figure things out and
so the thing that gets you through is
that passion to see it through to the
end goal but the willingness to learn i
think is what helps you understand how
to how to break through so this
interesting question but I said I would
go it and to your point I mean most of
us have access to a local library Google
and YouTube and I feel like with those
three things combined there's really no
limitation to what you can learn and I
think you know YouTube is the best
example of that like if you want to
learn how to slice the perfect tomato
there's a youtube video for that and if
you want to learn how to end and record
a podcast record edit submit a podcast
to iTunes there's a series of videos for
that too and I think it's just a matter
of like you said the passion the
determination the willingness to learn
the resources are all out there and most
of them are free so I think you know the
Internet has gotten to a point where
it's really democratized knowledge that
entrepreneurs need to be successful yeah
it's never been easier like I wish I had
youtube is right I had to read that book
every day but name I had this I thought
I remembers I remember coating my first
website reading a book on HTML right you
know and because there weren't as many
resources out there to do it it was you
know you would get one of those those
big text books that will walk you
through it but now there's a youtube
video to guide you through and it's so
much more easy and intuitive yeah cool
so the next question comes back to the
the theme of today's your day and it's
asking about just getting out of the
mentality so some people have a
mentality that they can't do what they
want that they're locked into a certain
situation and they're not able to change
their situation how do you break through
that mentality either like if it's a
friend of yours or if it's yourself
feeling like your box standing is no way
out and today is not
dat'll never knew my day how do you how
do you break free of that mentality
again it goes back to baby steps so
identifying what it is that you want to
achieve what you want to do and really
making it a point to elevate that goal
um obviously if if you work a
nine-to-five and you need to work that
nine-to-five for for your income for
your benefits what have you um you know
I'm not advocating today's your day to
just up and quit your job you know I'm
advocating you know it's today's your
day to really identify what it is you
want to accomplish um if if that nine to
five or that is keeping you down if
that's getting you down if you're not
happy with your life situation I figure
out what it is that would make you happy
and the types of things that you would
want to accomplish the types of content
you want to create a types of that the
type of value you want to provide and
then take those baby steps and you know
it all comes together with with the
topics we're talking about time
management you know if you only have an
hour a day to work on something um or if
you don't have an hour day to watch
Netflix it might be time to sacrifice
that hour and not watch Netflix and and
start lining up those baby step tasks
that are going to get to get you to
where you want to be and allocating that
time maybe putting it on your calendar
google calendar is great or wake up an
hour earlier and make that first hour of
the day your day you know that's your
time that's a really great way to do it
is if you wake up at seven every morning
start waking up at six and then from six
to seven that's your time specifically
to not think about your nine to five and
not think about any hard situations you
have to deal with and just focus on
what's going to make you happy and your
passion projects yeah I think the I
think the environment matters a lot to
uh you look at look at this place like I
walk in and I see these apple and then
you know to you guys watching me or you
know who most of them are that may not
be inspiring to you but for me it's
inspiring I come in I look at this these
people are looking at me you know it
makes me want to go out and do more and
are these people that you're referring
to whether it's yourself or people in
your life if you look at their
environment it probably sucks like
there's nobody around them push them to
be better and just that's the way it's
always been done and the first thing
that really helped me break through with
that book that's why I love it so much
is I'm reading these pages of people
like Oprah who started with zero and
more you know potato sacks as dresses to
go to school right like started with
Wade last see what I already have now
like the fact you guys are watching is
enough access to the Internet now you're
starting with way more than what a lot
of people who've had success started
with that inspired me and so look at
your environment look at the resources
you consume podcasts and videos and
books look at your daily habits does it
help you break free of your current
comfort zone an immediate circle because
you may not have friends and parents and
people around you and teachers and
guidance counselors who push you to do
more and so don't blame them like take
it upon yourself to improve your
environment to improve your situation to
pay conscious attention to what's on the
walls where you work in to what you put
into your brain and consumed because
that will shape your beliefs and mindset
and help you break free of that limiting
limiting focus there's anything you do
Tom like what do you how do you surround
yourself with I know like the people
they wear gray but like your habits or
in your environment that pushes you to
be a better time than you were yesterday
yeah I mentioned podcasts earlier and I
think that's part of it for me is like
having kind of a daily um a daily
injection of entrepreneurs that inspire
me literally coming through my ears you
know like going into my head like I put
on headphones and I listen to podcast
and I listen to enthusiastic
entrepreneurs who are out there doing it
and really making a difference and
really growing their business and really
practicing what they preach um you know
I don't have a ton of entrepreneurial
friends and like you said or
about how the people who read your
emails get to know you through your
emails I get to know these entrepreneurs
through their podcasts into the content
that they create and you know I know I
wouldn't consider them and friends but
it's it's a an opportunity to surround
myself with people who are doing the the
things in creating the kind of energy
that I would want to create myself so I
think that that environment is huge I
totally agree with you so so when are
you listening to the podcast is that
like on your way to work when you own
your home lunch time all of the above
what's your like how does that fit into
your daily routine yeah it's it's a
commute thing for me so I used to listen
to music or the radio on the way to work
in the way home and I replaced that with
podcasts and I saw a giant um change in
my mentality you know and and just in
terms of being motivated and and focused
choosing the right content to fill that
time which used to be just idle time
listening to music where I wasn't even
paying attention to that you know making
a conscious choice to fill it with
something else in that environment was
was really helpful for me that's
interesting I'm wondering is Sarah can
you remember because that's kind of you
saying hey today is my day yeah yeah
that is it no what no more music I'm
gonna fill my head with knowledge to
motivate me do you remember like what
was going through your head or what
inspired that change to do that ship
from music to podcast uh I'm not a
morning person so I think that was part
of it you know i think it was it was a
decision that you know today is my day
to really change my morning routine so
that i can start every day off on the
right foot um and it started with a
couple i made a couple of changes i mean
i like i said i woke up earlier um to
focus on passion projects you know I
started eating a healthier breakfast in
the morning instead of skipping
breakfast and and I started listening to
podcasts that inspired me on the way to
work so I think all that together really
was the turning point and I made a
conscious decision to do
like there was a there was certainly a
today's your day moment to get me
through that interesting yep um there's
a bunch of people asking about how to
say no uh basically their family or
their bosses or people in their lives
are putting tons of responsibilities on
them and and they don't know how to say
no so that they can focus on their own
stuff is like sharing Zane Owens like
people are filling up the chat here
other do you have advice on how to say
no to people yeah um well I mean you
know with your with your boss and your
your work responsibilities and your kids
it's not always feasible to say no and I
think that there's a level of needing to
accept that and communicate maybe
communicate better with your boss and
your family if you feel like so if you
feel like what's being asked of you is
not manageable communication is key
right so instead of just saying no
communicate how you feel and communicate
what is manageable and and and where
you're at and just always keep that that
line of communication open but for
saying no to things outside of that that
purview so things outside of work things
outside of responsibilities with your
family if you google derek sivers de re
k sivers hell yeah you'll read a blog
post that he wrote in 2009 and he's from
a I believe he's from cdbaby com so he
started cdbaby com which was one of the
early kind of music online music
distribution type of services um and his
his mentality is uh if he's not saying
hell yeah when someone asks him to get
involved with something or do something
he's just going to say no uh so if it's
just like yeah I think I'll maybe I'll
do that or yes sure he'll just say no it
has to be he's a hundred and ten percent
committed he's excited about he's
passionate and that's like the hell yeah
test and I think it's cool I think it's
really a
liable lesson to be learned and
something to adopt because how many
times you say like like yeah sure you
know like well we'll come over for
dinner you know or you know wool I'll
help you you know rewrite your resume or
something like that you know i mean like
at a certain point you have to say no so
that you can focus on the things that
are most important to you hey Tom let me
ask you something we excited to come on
this YouTube penge today hell yeah
absolutely yes um I jumped at the
opportunity to do it if you were
following along at the entrepreneurs
page we were actually going to do a
different segment and then we decided we
pivoted we just started to focus on
today's your day and I was pretty
excited about that because that meant
that I got to come on instead of one of
my colleagues so for sure that's good
and you're dropping resources is always
a wealth of information and people love
it yeah I want to to this question I
mean I agree with Tom I think
communication is the way through I think
also if you're if you're in a
environment where like if you have a job
and all of this stuff that's coming to
you is not what you want to be doing or
way too much and the communication is a
work like maybe you're in the wrong job
to maybe you should be somewhere else I
would also add though that for your
personal and business life be great to
have chunked off time where this is your
time is your productive time and whether
you're waking up early in the morning
like Tom does that extra arrow for
passion projects or you know this is
really a problem for people who work
from home too because kids are always
knocking though or the spouse is always
ask you to do something and just knowing
that hey you're like when I'm here when
the door is closed or you know from this
time at this time this is like I need
this to be my productive time unless
it's a super emergency like leave me
alone maybe not the like that rudeness
but so they have an understanding hey
you of goals you're trying to accomplish
something big here is what I'm trying to
do I really need this time to focus on
myself and I'm open during the other
times and so having higher standards for
your time is important because if you
don't set up boundaries engaged then
people will walk all over you um
so it's an important muscle to start
building and find a really elegant way
to say no so don't just come right out
and say like no no I'm not interested or
no flick flat no you don't want to close
doors and you don't want to come off as
Kurt there's ways that you can find a
really a really elegant and professional
way to pass on something while keeping
the door open and keeping the
relationship really solid so just a good
example of that is I actually am the
host of the Aweber podcast and it's an
interview show so I contact a lot of
people for interviews and certain people
say no to the opportunity to be on the
podcast and they they say in such a way
where they say um thank you so much for
the opportunity so they start off by
saying thank you and they appreciate
that I reached out and they'll say I
would love to be on your podcast but I'm
currently a hundred percent focused on
my book launch or I'm a hundred percent
focused on creating this next product
and I'm working on and I've just been
turning down opportunities like this so
I can remain focused and I can't help
but respect that response uh you know I
respect them as an entrepreneur and I
respect them as a business owner for the
ability to say no to me even though I'm
only asking for 45 minutes of their time
if they said yes to everybody who asked
for 45 minutes of their time they would
probably have no time so I have to
respect their consistency and their
ability to say no for sure I like it um
next question kind of comes back to the
theme of today's your day asking about
people who are stuck in the mentality of
I am fine where I am so they don't
change so any not what we talked about
before about like fear of doing
something new and fear of leaving a job
or fear starting a YouTube channel but
just people feeling like you know what
things are things are okay I'm fine
where I am I don't want to challenge
myself yeah you know I think I think you
really need to dig deep and and and push
I think that you know it's you'll reach
a point where you feel content you feel
um you feel a level of comfort but i
think the real magic happens when you
step outside of your comfort zone i
don't know if you've experienced that in
your past Evan but it you know for me
even when I feel good and comfortable
and really happy with everything that
was going on if I took a solid look at
what I felt I was capable of doing
outside of that you could find areas of
opportunities to really push and and and
once you again saying today's your day
to go do this thing that I'm afraid of
or this thing that makes me
uncomfortable when you start doing that
I really awesome things start to unfold
and I think it's just a matter of
pushing yourself a little bit further
and trying out what's the worst that
could happen you go back to the spot
where you were you know yeah I think
it's good to develop an allergy to
mediocrity sure so that you're not just
mailing it in you like that I just made
that up Moses show you happy with that
oh yeah where you got just mailing in
you're not just doing it over and over
and over again and I think if you if you
have like if you have skills you have
abilities and you you know what
spider-man says with great what is it
with great with great power or
responsibility responsive on it um but
like if you have the ability to have a
bigger impact then it's your
responsibility to do it like not just
for yourself but for your family for
community for your country for the world
if you are able to do more not everybody
is able to do more but if you are able
to do more than then you owe it to
yourself and the people around you to do
more and I think a lot of people don't
necessarily have a bigger vision for
themselves and what they could be and so
they get stuck into like oh this is my
life this is where I am share maybe back
to the environment thing if you started
listening to podcast like Tom where you
start watching videos and a new world
kind of opens up to you real isn't Oh
like that's possible I want to go chase
that yeah I agree ah bunch of questions
coming in how do you get people to
listen to you I don't know how so how'd
it like tied
I can't like today's your day um like if
you want to go off and do something and
people aren't believing in you and they
tell ya you're crazy don't talk come on
that's a really stupid idea I don't do
that man like what would be doing how
did you get people to listen to you and
support you on that path III think just
being authentic and telling you know
telling the story of how you got to that
point where you felt compelled that this
is what you you needed to do I think
story is huge on you know and if if
enough people or if the people
immediately around you are not believing
in you or not are not a part of the
environment that's going to help you get
get to where you need to be I think
that's when it's time to start making
tweaks to your environment you know but
I think a communication is key and just
trying to tell the story and be
authentic and tell people why you care
about it is you want to do and try to
paint the picture of what you're out to
accomplish and hopefully they will
believe in you after that or start to
believe in you as you start to
accomplish the things that you want to
accomplish and if they are constantly
being naysayers obviously close friends
and family members you shouldn't just
cut them off um you know obviously but
start making tweaks your environment so
whether that's YouTube videos or
podcasts or meetup groups meetup groups
are great or you know many support
masterminds that you can find online
online communities you can join there's
a lot of opportunities to surround
yourself with people who do believe you
and I think that that's important mighty
like initial reaction to this is is just
stop living for the approval of other
people sure yep right like if you don't
want to do like I don't want to come on
because I'm afraid that somebody's going
to judge me that's not a great reason to
do it and and you may not have the
support of your parents you may not have
support your friends and it may think
you're crazy and stupid and go do the
safe thing and don't follow your path
even if what they're saying is out of
love like you should go and
this Tom you guys that's the best thing
for you like they're seeing the world
through their eyes and try to put their
experiences on you but you have to live
your life and the last thing that you
would want to do I think at least is you
know be 90 years old looking back and
your life and say man I really wish I
went did that but I did because you know
my grandma said it was a bad idea and to
get used to I this I have this concept
of army of one where when I'm starting a
new project that I'm really excited
about I will try to recruit people I
will try to build a team this is
important and if I can support people
around me it makes accomplishing my
mission that much easier but if I don't
get it if I can't recruit anybody have
nobody believes in me I will be an army
of one and I'm really into existence
because I wanted to be there and you
should take that approach like if the
people don't support you around you
being army of one find a way to make it
happen stuff it may be slower it would
be more painful but you owe it to
yourself to not live a life filled with
regret because you wished you believe in
yourself a little bit more 10 20 30 40
years ago and you know the adage show
don't tell really applies here too so
don't don't just tell your family and
your friends that you have an allergy to
mediocrity you know show them that you
have an allergy to mediocrity by making
a conscious decision not to be mediocre
and really putting out there your best
work and just doing it you know I think
what you said about being an army of one
is huge just go out there and do it
believe in yourself and when they see
that you won't even have to tell them if
anything they'll just see it they'll see
the transformation you'll see the good
work you're doing and and uh hopefully
that just translates into them starting
to come around and starting to believe
you if they don't if they don't who
cares right I mean that's you use the
negativity as power to feel you forward
yep go show them I like it um oh we're
getting short on time but let's get one
more question Jeju is written in hey I
have a voice in my brain for the last
seven years it tells me to start a
business and it does not go away is it a
good sign that's a great sign anytime
you have that that
that entrepreneurial itch that you just
can't scratch until you start something
I think it's time to take this step to
start it so to me that you know it is
absolutely like the phrase for today's
today's your day and I think if every
day you're waking up with that itch to
start a business or to start a pursuit
you know today is the day for you to do
that for sure because it's probably not
going to go away if it hasn't gone away
yet is probably not going to go away and
and you know like you just said earlier
you don't want to wake up being 90 years
old and looking back and say I really
wish you know you know back on sep
tember eighth of 2016 when I was
watching evident Tom do that silly
youtube show I really wish I would have
taken action I really wish I would have
taken that as the sign and the cue that
I should go start my entrepreneurial
journey you don't want to do that you
just want to you know even if you fail
you want to learn from your failures and
and and start the next thing move on to
the next thing but living with regret I
couldn't do it so you know it's just
keep keep keep your eyes on the prize
and keep moving forward for sure I love
it I couldn't put any better man that's
that's a great one that closed on uh Tom
man really appreciate the times day yep
for people who want to learn more about
the checklist resources to free
downloads and also you how to get in
touch what's what's the best way yeah so
i would definitely check out aweber calm
/ entrepreneurs dot HTM so just you have
to put that dot HTM on the on the end of
it but check out entrepreneurs dot HTM
over at Aweber calm you'll check out
some links to the previous sessions that
we did with Evan you can check out the
free resources that we put together from
those sessions and then on the last
block you can click over to Aweber calm
/ today where we have just a ton of
brand new checklist that we put together
so if you want to create an online
course record your first youtube video
create your first Facebook ad maybe you
want to start an email let
get your first 50 subscribers record
your first podcast we really try to
create a wide range of opportunities for
business owners entrepreneurs who aren't
sure how to take that next step to give
you the resources to really hope you do
it and you can just check those out and
you know reach out to us at any point
twitter is a great way so at a weber on
twitter I'm act enrt on Twitter you can
reach out to me directly but we are here
to serve entrepreneurs we believe in
entrepreneurs we believe in the mission
Evan of serving entrepreneurs as well
and it's not for us it's not just email
it's not just email marketing it's
everything it's finding your passion and
really capitalizing on it and and and
always moving forward with that next
step to serve your customers and serve
your people hello i love the heart and
tom knows those resources are all free
to write like the checklists and the
guys and all that is all free people to
get it's all free so the checklists the
resources from the previous videos those
are all free we're not even gonna ask
for your email address you know you're
not going to end up on any of our our
email list we do have some courses
listed there the courses require an
email address only because their email
courses so you have to give us your
email address so we can mail you the
course the course materials but but
that's it everything else the checklist
are online and downloadable and those
are all free love it well well people
love you in the chat tomm really
appreciate you spending your time thank
you for that thank you guys to watch you
think for all the questions continue to
believe make today your day yes totally
and we'll see you soon all right thank
you take care